e
okay it's 10: a.m. we'll get
going
we'll uh we'll start today with the
pledge as per
usual um get this going sorry I'm like
so out of it right
now okay good morning um going to open
up the special committee on child care's
public hearing on Senate Bill 478
relative to child daycare residential
care and child placing agency licensing
I want to welcome Senator Carson to the
committee for the purpose of
introduction of the Bill thank you very
much Mr chairman and good morning and
good morning to members of the committee
for the record my name is Sharon Carson
and I have the pleasure of representing
Senate District 14 comprising the towns
of Auburn London Derry and Hudson
for your consideration today I have
Senate Bill
478 um which does quite a few things and
we'll I'll go through them as I testify
but uh I would like to begin by saying
that this um bill was at the request of
the Department of Health and Human
Services um and members are here today
um to provide testimony and answer any
questions that you might have on Senate
Bill 478
Senate Bill 478 does the following one
it is consistent with existing
Department administrative remedies for
licensed daycare agencies and Recreation
camps the proposed legislation would
include licensed residential care and
child placing agencies also being
subjected to administrative fines for
non-compliance with the provisions of
its specific licensing subdivision RSA
170e colon
24 secondly it eliminates the issuance
of a child care employment eligibility
card currently required for licensed
daycare agencies under RSA
170e colon 7 section 4A and a licensed
residential care and child placing
agencies under RSA
170e uh Colin 29
A7 this requirement is no longer
necessary we staff eligibility
information is readily available to
employers via the New Hampshire
connections information system
portal third it eliminates the
requirements for RSA
17010 which is the child care uh child
daycare lure and RSA 170e colon 33
residential care and child placing
licensure that the department shall give
notice to the health officer and Fire
Department of the the city or town in
which the license C is located stating
the granting of such license and its
terms not withstanding local officials
are directly included and involved in
the initial lure application process and
the results of lure issuance is publicly
available online via the Department's
website thus this provision of law has
become unnecessary yet remains an
additional resource Demand on the
department and four at amends RSA
17031 to align specialized care
licensing from a 2 to a three-year
licenser cycle with other entities
licensed by the Department's child care
licensing unit at this point Mr chairman
I'm going to terminate my comments and
please ask you to hold your questions
until the people who requested the bill
be filed can come up and talk to you
about it in more detail I thank you very
much for your time this morning thank
you um uh can I get U we'll do a Jackie
C cowl next
um uh can we get a pink card from the
Department hello hello good morning uh
how do you do I'm Jack Cowell from Early
Learning New Hampshire we're a Statewide
nonprofit and glad to be here with you
you again we do support sp sp 478 um in
particular very excited about the
childcare employee eligibility cards no
longer being necessary that's been a
burden to the field and to child care
small businesses and employers as well
so this is terrific and um uh just want
to mention that the folks the leadership
from the legislatively enacted New
Hampshire childcare advisory Council
couldn't be here today they're
prescheduled for a meeting but they they
um wanted me to let you know that they
also support this bill
will we be taking questions are there
questions I don't have yeah sure okay
two things all right than thank you
we'll get the Department up
next good morning members of the
committee um my name is Melissa Clement
I'm the chief of the childcare licensing
unit in the Department of Health and
Human Services and I'm happy to answer
any questions you have on the bill the
way it was presented is consistent with
what we recommended
so if you have any questions I'd be
happy to answer them are there any
questions from the
committee uh yes appr um so the
information about like informing the
local Health officer and fire department
um presumably that's so that they're
aware that
there's yes and it when when we notify
them it comes after the fact um so thank
you for allowing me to provide
clarification the programs have already
gone to their local towns to get zoning
approval the fire inspector has already
inspected it the health officer has
already inspected it so they're well
aware that the application process is
happening um and everything else is
available online once we issue the
license
so thank
you further
questions uh I can you talk to me about
the new section um page three Section 8
U sorry uh about the new $2,000
penalty sure absolutely so um our
residential program Child Care programs
which are our 24-hour care programs for
youth um we do not have a fine structure
in place for them and the reason we
wanted to add it is so that we have a
consistent process with child daycares
and our camp programs but also to allow
us additional remedies because right now
we would go from we cite them on a
statement of findings they provide a
corrective action plan we then have the
option to either suspend or revoke their
license there's nothing there's no
middle ground so we go from the you know
the one citation to or not just one
citation but after repeat citations
there's no other remedy and it has been
found that in general when we're working
with programs sometimes administering a
fine is what helps in order for them to
be able to
understand the need to maintain
compliance so it's for us it's an
intermediate step it's not one we do
lightly we always there is always a
history of repeat citations or egregious
findings before we get to that point we
just wanted the ability to have that
flexibility that we have with our other
license agencies throughout the
department any further
questions okay San thank you um thank
you very much we'll just uh chill till
10:15 U and we're gonna we're voting on
this in 10:15 so if you want to break
into a caucus that that's
fine
e
okay it's 10:15 we're going to in our
period of executive session on Senate
Bill 478 relative to child daycare
residential care and child placing
agency licensing um I will make a motion
uh that 478 FN should be ought to pass
is there a
second representative wner seconds
there's any discussion on the bill
hearing none the clerk will call the
role
yes
hi uh votes
yes well I'd like to
vote
Yes not voting okay all right with that
the motion of op passes uh on Senate
before s cares on a vote of 7 to zero uh
I'll take care of the committee report
I'll get it done here for noon and I
will see you guys on tomorrow
thanks